jumping on in i am a big fan of matthew
vaughn you guys have both worked with
many directors i'm curious was what is
it really like working with matthew
vaughn that perhaps you you know for
fans of his that maybe they wouldn't
expect or wouldn't know
matthew's one of the great entertainers
you know um not only does he know what
an audience wants
um he also
he kind of knows what they
um don't know they want
um
and he you know whatever you say about
matthew you know the kingsmen in
particular
i think kingsman fans don't expect only
to be satisfied with the next they
expect to be surprised uh and this film
certainly does that you know um and
matthew matthew he's an extraordinary
director his kind of um
his camera grammar
is something i've never experienced
before you know he he he he seems to
have
um
a cinema in his head and he's able to
project
um
decisions onto that screen in his head
in the moment on the day
so he's he he's leaps and bounds ahead
of anyone else on the floor you know in
terms of how the language of the camera
and how the camera is going to impact
the audience when it's projected you
know he has that innate capability you
know to to
to do that and it's a real kind of um
it's humbling to be around you know um
to watch someone work at that level you
know um
i i was a huge fan of his work anyway
and i'm an even bigger fan of of him as
a person
uh but you know as a director it's um
and he's also kind of you know as
cutting edge as he is he's also quite
old-fashioned you know in
in the sense that he doesn't beat around
the bush you know he's he doesn't come
with politeness if he doesn't like
something he will shout across the floor
boring
dude i mean i kind of love that factory
floor vibe you know that that you you're
just there to
to work you know and to get this thing
built and done and and ready for
production
so yeah a joy to work with
uh i would think that i uh had met him
for the first time about uh
a decade ago
shortly after they finished a snatch but
i had met him many years before that
uh while i was a you know a model in
paris moving to california and
he was a young filmmaker
you know uh in hollywood i did not know
and so he knew
uh
a roommate of mine and um and so over
the years i had met with him shortly
after they finished snatching you know
was in the hopes of uh potentially
working with him
and uh and so this came about and i was
like a a
a very uh
no-brainer yes
and uh because i've admired so much of
his work and obviously given the first
two uh installment of kingsman
uh that had been very successful
and you knew he's got a particular style
and and obviously
the fans of a
kingsman have a high expectation coming
onto these films because
uh once you see this uh
way of uh this particular sort of like a
action sequence you know in the next
film he will exceed himself
you know
speaking of action sequences i loved the
fight between you guys
that whole
um
the whole sequence with the way that
matthew had
uh you like with jiu jitsu and karate
and also russian ballet like it was one
of the most unique things i've seen this
year can you sort of both of you talk
about filming that sequence because it
looks so great on film and it's unlike
things that people are going to see
yeah we we we spent you know jaimin and
i and and rafe and harris you know spent
like months in uh readying ourselves
physically um in order just to complete
a day just just in terms of stamina you
know it took two or three weeks to shoot
that sequence uh and then of course so
we worked with the trainer and then we
worked with the the stunt team daily you
know for for months
trying to um
come up with
versions and variations of what that
fight might be and but more specifically
trying to find a language that was a
physical language that was unique to
rasputin matthew was very keen to
explore that and we tinkered with
everything but we you know we we kind of
weren't
quite getting there and matthew burst
into the stunt room one day and said
i've got it
um
russian dancing and martial arts mix
them up you know and um and that again
you know his testament to matthew's
crazy but brilliant mind you know and
then of course this exquisite stunt team
that we were working with under brad
allen who sadly passed away um slowly
but surely came came up with this
um
this kind of satanic marriage between
these two disciplines
and um and it was formulated and then we
worked
you know intensively and albeit
separately you know with with stunt
doubles to work on the fight and then
finally we came together
on the set and um and shot it and it it
was a world of pain
um
and it really was wasn't it i mean it
was just it was tough hard-going work
not just for us obviously for they were
they were it's it's it's it's the
accumulation of of the work of
you know tens of of of people who are
who are the top of their game you know i
i can't stress that enough stunt men um
two two wonderful georgian dancers from
from georgia who were flown over um it
was a huge kind of collaboration and
it's really satisfying as an actor to
walk away from that and then
see the finished product you know it's
really kind of moving actually because
you know
that it involved
the dedication of so many people over
over weeks and months
i mean listen i've been in a number of
films uh you know action driven films uh
before
and coming on to matthew films uh you
know i thought okay um i had a
you know great background of uh in
martial art and boxing and i thought
okay this should you know just show me
what you want to do
and so to show me it wasn't as
you know that simple i end up
uh doing so much training and the
training some of the training led to a
bit of an injury and that that
injury you had to nurse the injury and
certainly
when every time i i heard action i would
put myself together and act like as if
as if i didn't have uh
you know
yeah
painful knee um so yeah and
that experience in itself uh what like
uh ray said um you know
when you see the finished product it's
quite gratifying so that in essence
i'm thankful for it
uh yeah it really turned out great uh
this is my last question for you guys um
i love talking to actors about the way
that they prepare for like a big scene i
love learning about how they how they
prep
as actors um so for both of you guys if
you have like a big scene on
pardon me on like a monday and you know
it's going to be emotionally charged or
take a lot out of you can you sort of
talk about how you're getting ready to
do that scene is it like a week in
advance a month in advance like
like how basically how you get ready for
an emotionally charged scene
i um
have it playing
quietly um
[Music]
in the in my interior distance you know
it's not something that's at the
forefront of my mind
um i like
scenes like that to take me by surprise
you know
um in some ways you can you can over
prepare you know
um
um
[Music]
yeah it's um and on a day like a big
scene like that generally i i'd have
like a quiet day you know not a day of
study not necessarily even a day of
preparation you know just a day of um
you want to kind of come to it with um
come at those
scenes with with an innocence
and um
and let's let the moment surprise you um
[Music]
surrender to that
the mood of that moment surrender to
that um
i would say um
a bit of the preparation it starts early
um just to get
an essence of where you add in a story
or in a scene this particular scene what
is your
uh backstory prior to that
and then work out all those little
bitty uh things
and the day of
it's more of a meditation day
just for that scene i think
on that note i gotta stop i'm just gonna
say again how much i enjoyed this movie
and your guys's performances thank you
so much for giving me your time
thank you thank you
happy holidays
you